anunciaron un toque de queda hasta nuevo
aviso soldados de las fuerzas especiales
patrullan las calles de la capital tras
reivindicar la destitución del
presidente guineano que más ha durado en
el cargo alpha condé esta escena llega
horas después de fuertes tiroteos cerca
del palacio presidencial un vídeo no
verificado empezó a circular en redes
sociales el domingo donde se ve a conde
rodeado de los soldados que asaltaron el
poder y disolvieron el gobierno
autodenominados comité nacional para la
reagrupación y el desarrollo afirmaron
que el golpe es una respuesta a la
corrupción y a la pobreza generalizada
en el país
no volveremos a confiar la política a un
solo hombre la confiaremos a todo el
pueblo
en declaraciones a la televisión
nacional la noche del domingo el grupo
aseguró que el presidente no está herido
pero tampoco reveló su ubicación número
ahora sobre las comitivas garantizamos a
la comunidad nacional e internacional
que la integridad física y moral del
expresidente no esté en peligro
y los militares cerraron las fronteras
de guinea pero la mañana de este lunes
la rea vieron el grupo también ordenó a
la élite política nacional reunirse este
lunes la onu y la unión africana
condenaron los hechos pero en este
bastión de la oposición los ciudadanos
celebraron la noticia
estamos muy muy contentos con lo que
hemos oído y escuchado
guinea ha vivido fuertes momentos de
convulsión social desde que conde fue
reelecto para un controvertido tercer
mandato después de cambiar la
constitución para saltarse el límite de
dos períodos presidenciales lo que
desató protestas masivas en el país